[Música]
como estourar a bolha social como sair
da bolha social da pobreza central para
pobreza periférica 1997
a minha história é contada com o que
admite mesmo tinha uma dor até que eu
passei no concurso público
eu ia ganhar o suficiente para ir a
outros lugares que eu sempre quis dizer
eu ia poder ajudar melhor a minha
família ia poder comprar as roupas de
frio a parte mais importante as roupas
de frio
fui pra um lugar que nunca tinha ouvido
falar parque do sabiá
bom de lá qual o ônibus que chegava e
fui andei andei eu que sou rapper cantei
vai cantar já fez apresentações em
vários lugares da cidade de piracicaba
cheguei num bairro chamado etapa que já
tinha apresentado foi a de que logo ali
estão chegando não andei mais um pouco
até que eu cheguei
cheguei no fim do meu 20 mesmo quando eu
vi um menino nu em julho de 1997 era um
dos dias mais frios aqui em piracicaba
crime não estava num entrei na escola me
mandado para o berçário trabalho na
educação infantil
logo chegou esse menino com pouca roupa
e muita fome
percebi isso porque na hora que ele
chegou ele ficou na portinhola que
divide a sala de aula
ea cozinha do berçário ele ficou ali até
o horário de saída o leite da manhã
o café da manhã ali mudou minha vida
ali eu sair da minha boca social 21 anos
lá não pedir remanejamento tive meus
filhos caiu tem além de oito nomes
africanos
lindiwe a esperada eu vi quando tinha 17
anos num curso que eu fiz no clube 3 de
maio e caiu de quando fazia capoeira é
eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa para
aquele lugar
vamos fazer uma peça de teatro
funcionários todo porque lá tinha pouca
opção tive essa brilhante idéia saiu o
terrível um sofrimento um sofrimento
vou começar a fazer uma aula de teatro
aí pra aprender no sesi tem curso para
iniciante e assim eu trago de volta pra
gente fazer melhor
fui fazer aos 31 anos esse curso de
teatro
hoje em dia sou atriz participei de dois
filmes gente olha o que a região oeste
fez por mim eu tinha uma bolha social
dentro de mim eu me descobri lá eu pude
perceber tudo de bom que os meus pais
deram pra mim por ter privilégio de ser
uma pobre central tudo estava ali
o teatro estava ali a salvo estava ali
todas as apresentações era muito fácil
de chegar o 15 de piracicaba estava ali
minha mãe sempre me levou nas
apresentações de dança de música no
teatro municipal
foi ali que eu resolvi então falar vou
trazer o torcedor de volta vou ter que
fazer alguma coisa nessa região oeste
que me fez descobrir
foi então que resolvi montar uma
biblioteca em casa
em 2010 o montar uma biblioteca em casa
dois quartos pequenos a cozinha bota
chamei meus dois filhos falei olha vamos
desocupar um quarto ea gente faz de lama
biblioteca joguei nas redes sociais
saiu no jornal local saiu na região céu
na record
meu filho quando falei de montar e fez
uma cara são gente pontuou
quando sair todos esses veículos
eu comecei a ganhar um livro do brasil
inteiro gente eu não tinha mais sala não
tinha mais corredor aquela cara do meu
filho eu entendi não funcionou
doamos o livro pra para uma casa de
recuperação que tem na região oeste
gente eu tinha que fazer algo de volta
tinha que trazer pra lá o que me deram
de presente
foi quando começamos a fazer coisas no
final da minha rua que eu apelidei
carinhosamente de hashtag o barranco é
nosso
minha rua é uma rua que não tem saída
onde os carros fazem um balão e tem um
barranco que o trator passou e deixou
ali a gente tem teatro tem contação de
história tem apresentação de música
festinhas tem várias coisas uma certa
vez o coletivo piracema trouxe para
piracicaba há semanas e da semana
audiovisual seda
nesta semana a gente passou um filme lá
foi quando a gente fez o primeiro cine
barranco mas com um projetor emprestar e
tudo mais possamos um filme lá quando
sinto que já sei um documentário
foi muito lindo todos sentados
assistimos que pensar periferia não vai
prestar atenção mentira
sentamos assistiu foi muito lindo o que
acontece quando estourou a bolha social
parceria um dia amigas me chamaram para
fazer parte de um projeto chamado
curto-circuito lugar onde o peixe não
pára
porque lá tem muita tem nada né falta de
opção num em julho de novo como quer
fazer crianças jovens estarem lá mas
tinham 18 jovens fazendo e se essa
oficina de desenho que o sesc comprou
também a ideia e trouxe um artista no
último dia desse curso
resolvemos perguntar o que as crianças
que iriam para o bairro desenharam
algumas coisas que a gente montou um
livro desse projeto mas três ou quatro
jovens crianças desenharam uma sala de
cinema para aí gente cinema a gente não
tem nos bairros gente tem que se
deslocar
foi quando eu perguntei quantos daqui já
foram ao cinema
três jovens levantaram-no as mãos
falei não a gente vai vender pizza
chamei mais três mulheres lá do bairro
mais um amigo e começamos a vender pizza
gente onde eu tava vendo a pizza fosse
agora nessa época estava vendendo pizza
pra vocês e vendendo pizza é bom porque
a gente queria comprar um projetor e de
direito ao cinema quando a gente
quisesse uma vizinha chegou em mim falou
assim olha eu estou cozinhando no fundo
do quintal no tijolo mas eu quero
comprar sabe o que é fazer uma população
pobre com transporte público ruim uma
saúde ruim acreditar que a cultura que
eles podem ter lazer
isso aconteceu ela veio com o dinheiro
que ela podia juntar para comprar o gás
comprar pizza eu não aceitei
mas ela faz hoje parte da organização do
cine barranco porque a gente conseguiu
o projetor
conseguimos através também tenham terra
mate um instituto que entrou porque a
gente se espalhou a história da terra
mas a gente tem aqui um projetor
vamos lá vamos fazer uma coisa junto
então a gente passa quando a gente bem
quiser filme faz festinha de criança eu
tô falando porque eu acredito que lá
através do movimento social da cultura e
da educação popular está acontecendo a
diferença
o local onde o primeiro primeira reunião
de pais que eu fiz com a minha turma
uma mãe falou que tinha que esconder o
local antes demorava para conseguir um
trabalho de empregada doméstica melhor
na cidade
aqui a gente estou falando de oito
quilômetros
eu estou falando de um local onde agora
está chegando uma internet que não seja
via rádio
eu estou falando de um local mais
populoso de piracicaba e mais pobre onde
existe uma única lan house com três
computadores onde eu estava lá
duas crianças fazendo um trabalho quando
acabou o lógico cabo e internet via
rádio e ouvir elas ainda dando aí como é
que a gente vai falar com a professora
que a gente não tentou fazer trabalho
foi aí que eu faço parte do maria de
lutas de alguns movimentos sociais ocupe
o largo
sou da casa do hip hop então tem uma
geladeira o teca no bairro é frente das
culturas de piracicaba
foi aí que várias lutas me convenceu a
fazer parte do conselho da mulher só uma
conselheira agora da periferia
pra políticas públicas
elas precisam de voz se eu consigo
transitarem entre esses dois mundos
vamos lá é e assim estão acontecendo as
coisas eles não estão mais aquela
questão de a banana começa aqui chega
por lá mas tá bom pra mim tá bom
autoestima melhorou 2018
a minha autoestima
eu sou agora da região oeste gente não
só trabalha lá
moro há 12 anos
neste bairro o meu bairro
chama-se santa fé anda com phelps que a
fé não costuma faiá anda confel vôo que
a fé não costuma faiá anda com phelps
conquistou uma faya anda com favor da fé
não costuma faiá tem muita coisa pra
acontecer lá esse ano já aconteceu feira
da economia solidária onde três mulheres
já saíram de lá para fazer feira porque
eu faço parte do respira rede de
economia solidária na primeira feira
tinham 40 mulheres respondem a maioria
mulher negra
uma delas conseguiu abrir uma loja agora
que no centro
tem que ter muita fé tem que ter muita
fé fé em cidade a todas ea todos
obrigada
[Aplausos]